we want a season sorry I never showed up
but I got married I had a baby I went
back to school got my GED what did you
do while you were waiting hopefully you
didn't just around and waste your life
oh we see you for season four and like a
really long time I might even have a big
white Santa Claus beard see you see then
hey everybody this is gonna be my first
season for video talking about all the
stuff that's coming back what the
writers have said behind the scenes and
things that have actually been confirmed
along with what the Rick and Morty video
schedule is gonna be during the off
season there will be weekly Rick and
Morty I'll still be doing the weekly
giveaway and if there are any other TV
series or things you want me to do
videos for let me know in the comments
but be sure to subscribe to get
everything so starting off with the big
things first a lot of people are asking
about the Santa Claus episode theory so
mr. poopy butthole says that he might
have a big white Santa Claus beard when
he comes back like there might be a
Christmas episode BBC Doctor Who style
the BBC is just known for doing special
one-off Christmas episodes for a lot of
its biggest drama series so I think
largely based on that and the idea that
they did the April Fool's Day special
episode like they aired it as a one-off
they might do something like that again
when season four comes back but there
hasn't been any indication from the
writers that that's their intention this
is actually something that one of the
writers said like don't people get tired
of being wrong about stuff like this
like he's saying that they're probably
not intending to do that this will get
into where they are in their season for
production because if they actually did
have a season four episode that would
air this Christmas that means they would
have had to send it off for animation
before the summer even started it takes
at least six months to animate most
episodes so this is actually a pretty
clear timeline once they finish writing
and recording episodes and send them off
to be animated but based on previous
experience in the way they treat
characters that they bring back and big
ongoing storylines some of these are
actually pretty easy so I'll just count
down from 10 so number 10 we're staying
in the same reality that's probably the
most obvious thing that's why they kept
saying in the episode that jumping to
another
reality would be a super-huge and
why Rick had to become fake fly-fishing
Rick at the end of the episode so that
he could stay in this reality and
function the way that he had previously
but just like they did in season 3
episode 1 season 4 episode 1 we'll
probably just have a quick line of
dialogue about all the craziness that
happened during season 3 and what
they've been doing since then number 9
they're not gonna go back to Beth being
a clone versus being real they're
probably never address it again in a
really big way maybe a joke here there
but the whole idea with that line of
dialogue that she has is that Rick would
never tell us and he's not gonna kill
her so regardless of where you fall in
that spectrum she's just gonna be
treated like the main version of Beth
but number 8 Rick's status in the family
like they say everything's being reset
to season 1 he'll continue to be treated
as the lowest status member so at the
beginning of season 3 he sort of took
control the family
this is them resetting that back to the
beginning of season 1 so the end result
of that is that Rick will get to do
whatever he wants to do morty and summer
will continue to be allowed to go on
potentially life-threatening adventures
and Beth isn't gonna take him to task
about it Jerry might not be happy about
it like he wasn't happy during season 1
but Dan Harmon explained a long time ago
part of the core concept of the show is
that Beth idolizes Rick so she hopes
that someday Morty might turn into a
Rick which is why she allows him to go
on these adventures with him but Morty
just continuing the theme of him slowly
getting older or getting smarter will
just continue to be more assertive with
Rick now even if you play it fast and
loose with how much older he's getting
on the show like The Simpsons for
instance are perpetually stuck at their
current age but it seems like Rick and
Morty is actually moving in real time so
like he gets a little bit older each
season even though they don't directly
address it that much we saw his 13th
birthday so if he was 14 around season 1
he should be at least approaching the
age of 17 but that kind of seems like
where summer is so I'm assuming they're
just getting a little fast and loose
with how old they get but you still have
to assume that off-screen Rick is still
using that memory gun every once in a
while like they might never go back to
that room but it's just an easy way for
them to control his rate of development
because otherwise he would probably go
crazy instantly like he wanted to kill
himself after he got all
memories back and that's just after the
previous seasons not after anything that
might end up happening during season
four and there's all these adventures
that we don't wind up seeing like you
have to assume that they go on
adventures all the time in between
episodes let's go 20 minutes adventure
but just like we saw new secret rooms
and new secret gadgets sort of emerge
out of nowhere Doctor Who style inside
Rick's lab we'll probably see more of
that in season four usually what that
ends up being just depends on the story
that they want to tell like is either a
room full of Rick clones or it's a room
full of memories so whatever stories
they want to tell during season four
they'll just create another room for
that or other gadgets like the squirrel
gadget that pops up out of nowhere out
of the table or any of the weapons or
things that he has hidden around the
house you have to assume that there's
more of that that we just haven't seen
yet just because they haven't needed it
for a story but even though they rolled
back the Beth Jeri divorce thing and it
seems like they're together now I think
they'll slowly slide back to their
dynamic in season one where she sort of
resents him just a little bit but
they're still in somewhat of a loving
relationship but Dan Harmon did say
something funny about his own parents
like a lot of Beth Jeri divorce stuff is
based on his own experience in real life
with his parents who got divorced and
then later got back together but mr.
poopy butthole the meeseeks squatchy
will all come back in various roundabout
ways like we saw meeseeks during that
Star Trek parody but they didn't
actually like physically come back in a
legit episode and the same thing with
squatchy - like he's mostly connected to
that Federation storyline so if we see
him again it might just be in a picture
or a memory mr. poopy butthole style
like we got that post-credits end tag
with him but that was mostly a funny
riff on the season two post-credits
scene that wasn't them bringing him in
like the Total Recall episode where he
was a really fundamental part of the
narrative
thanks mr. poopy butthole I always could
count on you but the interesting thing I
think about this too is they haven't
revealed whether or not they always plan
to tag him at the end of this episode
sort of setting up a delay for season
four like Oh see you in a very very long
time or if that's just a way for them to
sort of wink at the idea that it took
forever to get to season three buts
of people coming back phoenix person and
Tammy we didn't see them again after
episode one so at some point they're
still alive they're still stuck in this
reality that we're currently in so
they're around there somewhere in the
universe
but the whole point of that story during
the first episode was to sort of table
that ongoing season 1 season 2 narrative
of the Federation trying to get his
portal technology like saying that okay
we're done with this storyline so when
they do come back it'll be a little bit
different they'll still want to take
Rick down and they still probably want
access to other realities but it'll have
to be a little more insidious because he
took out a large portion of their fleet
so there's a couple of them left and now
really the big ethereal threat in the
multiverse is evil Morty so obviously
evil Morty will come back in some way
he'd already upended the power structure
between Morty's and their Rick's on the
Citadel even without moving directly
against c-137 Rick he'll probably
continue to try and spread that paradigm
throughout the multiverse so the more
Morty's you have being assertive in
distracting their Rick's the fewer
Rick's there are to figure out what evil
Morty is doing and stop him so I think
there'll be a lot of chaos going on in
the background and we can make all kinds
of theories about evil Morty forming an
alliance with Phoenix person and Tammy
but I think when they do come back
they'll come back separately before they
come back together if that is really
where they're headed but really the
first big one you guys will like this so
season four will be 14 episodes like we
were promised in season 3 technically so
Dan Harmon actually explained that
originally they'd intended for season 3
to be 14 episodes but because of the
delay they had to adjust their plans so
because of all the changes they made
behind the scenes to get season 4 out
faster he said what they're gonna do is
they'll deliver the first 10 episodes
that they would normally deliver to
Adult Swim then go back to them and say
here the other 4 episodes that we want
to do this season I've already addressed
that Christmas episode theory so if it
does take them a little bit longer than
next summer to get episodes out it's
because they're doing that extra 4 so
remember it takes about six months to
animated an episode the writers finished
writing season 3 last October they went
on like a probably brief hiatus then
came back and started writing season 4
so they've actually been writing season
or scripts this entire year like
literally this entire time we've been
waiting to get episodes they've actually
already been working on season four the
whole reason why Adult Swim hasn't
confirmed when season four is coming or
even that it's coming at all is because
Dan Harmon and Justin roiland contracts
were up at Adult Swim so while I think
it'll all work out we will get our
season four they really want to give it
to us they just have to figure out the
business stuff behind the scenes and
once that's locked down then they'll say
okay we're working on season four and
they'll start tweeting stuff out but
what will happen next is I'll do a Q&A
video so anything you have about season
four or stuff from season three you want
me to include in that just write it in
the comments below
and that'll post tomorrow during the off
season what I'll probably do is I'll at
least be doing Rick and Morty on
Saturdays and once or twice during the
week but I'll be doing theory videos any
news that drops about season four or
anything from behind the scenes or
things that they release so if you have
special requests just let me know in the
comments and if there are other TV
series that you want me to do videos for
just let me know
but the weekly giveaway will continue
right now it's for the Zen monkey
studios merch it'll be for the season 3
DVD when they announce that's coming out
so as soon as that hits pre-order that's
what the giveaway will be for all you
have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
congratulations to the winner from the
last video Derrick stall please private
message me so I can get your contact
details you can click here for my finale
video and you can click here to start
getting ready for the blast season 4
which is coming back next week thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]